how's it going my name is markiplier
okay I thought you were gonna slam the
door or you're not done would you be
something some real hard out on that
Bing bong downstairs no I don't know
what else you got for me game huh
yeah actually gonna be spooky huh you
gonna try to scare me hang on my nose
[Applause]
please thank you for can you please take
it up a notch okay well the party came
and went
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you okay
goodbye this is how we're gonna play
this game it's a chain link death funnel
pointing me into the desk building where
I gotta go turn off the death antennas
alright fine whatever let's do this babe
ooh giraffe oh it's adorable oh it's
adorable oh it's got blood on it that
makes it twice as adorable old book okay
what good is that gonna do me okay great
my sister didn't scare me also I can't
fathom what the point of these you know
I'm done questioning things I get it I
understand I'm about to die I know this
I I should just accept my fate keel over
and just kiss my ass good-bye
hello seems awfully wet in here so just
to set the mood Lulu
[ __ ] goddamn it stop hey fuzz [ __ ]
fuzz but now that's a cute name [ __ ] you
I like me a good room what's not a naked
streaker was that a streaker was that a
streaker in the middle of the sky damn
mine was there someone running naked in
this goddamn mine cuz that's something
that I will not stand for okay
why aren't they after the balls why am i
after the balls frankly I can do without
the balls you know what yeah okay that
didn't happen that's uh someone
connecting to the internet from the
1994's
that was a good joke me thanks come on
do it for me come on oh god not that
that's not what I wanted you're a big
fella I don't want you you gobble
something else I'm trusting this I don't
know why I'm trusting this ghosties over
the fear sneeze Oh God I'm not sneezing
Octus back oh you want some or you want
some of my sexy body but you can't have
it you can't have it you couldn't handle
all of this sexy no if that stupid mouth
of yours oh never mind then